ich darf roland palmert interview das
ist ja wahnsinn hier auf dem campus
mitten in manhattan
sie leben doch schon dauern von so einem
wochenendtrip nach manhattan
das wird fantastisch wir kennen das
alles schon ein bisschen die gleiche das
gleiche thema variiert immer wieder
eigentlich seit jahrzehnten die einst in
das steht was ist los du wolltest mich
doch vor 30 minuten anrufen timmer diese
jungen männer bei ihm die dann diese
frauen haben und wie sind diese frauen
haben so ihren eigenen kopf und das ist
alles sehr sehr schwierig da das ihr
erster bericht wird wie wäre es dann mit
einem echten lombok hier schafft das
allerdings einen ganz interessanten dreh
zu nehmen denn nicht alle frauen sind
nur komisch verkaufte schwierig gewesen
sondern dieses lina gomez figur
beispielsweise die shannon
die hat ihren kopf schon richtig und
wichtig für das war dein mund aufmacht
ich habe eine freundin ständig kann das
nicht konfrontiert ihn ein bisschen mit
seiner eigenen privilegiert haltung mit
seinem ganzen dieser ganze blase in der
sozusagen wohnt und lebt und sein leben
bis jetzt verbracht hat feind ist das
technisch etwas geld seiner eltern bei
schwester was meinst du damit ich meine
du kanntest ihren job suchen aussehenden
studium selbst finanzieren
jetzt war es gibt eine ganz tolle kamera
arbeit von vittorio story italienischer
kameramann der schon mit drei oscars
ausgezeichnet wurde und sich nicht um
darlehen und wally ist super und
zufrieden damit du lässt dich die müssen
den finken gefahr einen seiner anfälle
kriegt er arbeitet wahnsinnig viel mit
warmen und kalten licht das heißt in den
richtigen momenten wo die richtigen
pärchen konstellation zusammen kommen
ändert sich plötzlich auch die
beleuchtung und die farben werden
geringer oder verblassen
es wird sozusagen ganz subtil schon
geführt wer hier eigentlich mit wem sehr
gut zusammen passen würde und welche
konstellationen eigentlich gar nicht so
richtig auch so ist einfach passiert wir
haben dagegen angeht
den kann ich mir vorstellen in jedem
hotelzimmer auf der rückwand hier nicht
um sexy frau an der seite von gatsby mit
der dahin reist ist elf fanning die
heißt ashley ganz ganz außergewöhnlich
geschrieben weil man ist ja das kind von
außergewöhnlichen eltern und diese
ashley es wahnsinnig überdrehte hat sie
sind 20 uhr wege also die gibt wirklich
ist das gut oder schlecht pausbäckig
alles was man irgendwie geben kann als
schauspielerin um möglichst tapsig und
verwirrt rüberzukommen hält sie für das
tollste seit der erfindung der pille
danach
ich spreche mit franziska wegener ich
weiß es nicht und auch hier hat sie aber
so ihren eigenen kopf und fällt dann
doch nicht in jedem falle reihen die man
von gott die ist ja nur ein blödes
dummchen dass dadurch die handlung
stolpert mitnehmen könnte sozusagen also
das heißt sie ist das schon ein bisschen
schlauer gestaltet als figur als man das
auf den ersten blick erwarten würde wenn
man sie sich seite wachhaus weniger
verkehrt sein
ich werde dann hemmungslos aggressiv hey
ich kann ja schlecht reden was
bitteschön ist daran so geheimnisvoll es
sei denn da ist was im busch mit denen
es sei denn da ist was im busch mit den
jungs woody allen hat ja mal mit der
große faszination für bergmann
angefangen
schwedischer klassischer schwedischer
autorenfilmer und dessen dessen
faszination für die für die
beziehungsdramen sozusagen und was er
immer wieder probiert es sich irgendwie
an diesem an seiner idee von von
bergmann abzuarbeiten und an seiner idee
von was machen paare miteinander wie
funktionieren die konstellation
miteinander mit der straße und ein beste
frau das ist so ein klischee ist larry
er identifiziert sich mit dir
er nimmt mein aftershave und meine frau
ging interessierter wirklich rein dieses
völlig nach innen gewandt
wie agieren wir miteinander wie
reagieren wir aufeinander und das ist
auch nur aus dieser eine perspektive für
gewöhnlich von diesen sehr
privilegierten menschen die diese
probleme eben miteinander haben und er
zieht das aber einfach so durch ein
bisher momentan wieder am film also das
heißt es ist immer der gleiche film den
er macht aber in variationen und
manchmal kommt dabei was man sich sehr
gern angucken kann und das hier ist so
einer dem man sich sehr genau angucken
es war ein kleines interview von einer
stunde geplant und jetzt ist das ganze
wochenende geplatzt ich bin ein riesen
33 ist hier ein mantel aus das geht
nicht ich habe darunter nichts an